The royal houses of Europe had a way of preserving power-strategic inbreeding, until the bloodlines
twisted into something grotesque.
The Hapsburgs, for instance, their jaws jutting forward like the slow collapse of a crumbling
empire, their faces the physical manifestation of a system that had turned inward until it
could no longer breathe.
They were the perfect example of what happens when a family refuses to let go.
And so, we apply the same logic to the psyche.
Family isn't just a collection of people.
It's a system of inherited stories, grievances, expectations, failures passed down like a
cursed heirloom.
To master misery, you must refuse to individuate.
You must let your identity dissolve into the collective weight of what came before you.
This is family system entropy, the art of ensuring that your suffering is never yours alone, but
a shared burden, a communal effort in stagnation.
The first step is the enmeshment trap.
Family therapy calls it a state where boundaries dissolve entirely.
Your mother's sorrow becomes your own.
Your father's shame lingers in your chest like a second skin.
And by keeping the lines blurred, you guarantee that your misery is never isolated.
It's a contagion, a silent agreement that no one here is truly free.
Now, the instructions for generational stagnation.
Begin with the narrative loyalty test.
Adopt the family grudge list as your own.
If your parents haven't spoken to an uncle since 1994, neither will you.
This isn't just tradition.
It's a debt you never asked to inherit.
A social ledger of resentment, carefully balanced, ensuring that the past never stays buried.
Then there's the guilt currency.
Never ask for what you need.
Instead, let your silence speak.
You didn't understand.
You abandoned me.
Let the unspoken hang in the air a low simmer of conflict that never quite boils over.
This keeps the system in motion.
A machine of quiet suffering where no one dares to step out of line.
Next, the refusal to launch.
The family home is a fortress, a shield against the world's stressors.
Stay.
Linger.
Let the drama wrap around you like a security blanket.
This isn't safety, it's surrender.
By never leaving, you ensure you'll never become anti-fragile, never learn to thrive in the chaos of independence.
And finally, the comparison oven.
Your siblings, your cousins.
They are your measuring sticks.
Every holiday dinner is an audit, a slow unraveling of self-worth.
The menu is regret.
The dessert is the question.
Why can't you be more like them?
Ah.
The result?
You become an ancestral anchor, a human weight, holding down the past so tightly that movement is impossible.
You feel the ache of three generations at once, yet do nothing to lighten the load.
This is inherited misery, perfected.
Huh.
And then there's the year-end regrets.
The holidays peak family entropy.
The pressure to meet expectations.
The collapse into nostalgia.
The bitterness that settles like dust.
In the residence lob from December 24th, the subject captures it perfectly.
A family is a mountain.
You can climb it, or you can let it sit on your chest.
Choose the weight.
And of course, they always choose the weight.
The weight.